オーディエンスの皆さん
スピーカーの皆さん
そして
おちゃまのお茶の間の皆さん
こんにちはー
ありがとうございます
疲れてますかねちょっと
これまで6人ものスピーカーの素晴らしいスピーチを
a
僕も
機械室やこの会場で楽しんでおりました
学生スピーカーオーディションに6月に参加したんですけども
その時
2番目にスピーチをした吉野くん
このスピーチを食べながら見ることができず今日心待ちにしておりました
4色のスピーチを見ていると
とてもドキッとするものがありました
確かに
青春返してほしいですよね
高校生 a 君
彼の a 紹介があったのを覚えていますか
高校1年生
コミュニケーションが苦手
趣味は鉄道
それを見た瞬間
それ俺だ
q ふうに思ってしまいました
そう一つ
最近悩んでいることがあるのです
話が苦手なんです
人と話をしているとどうしても話が盛り上がらないんです
で会話がストップしてしまうんです
そんな話を先日ある友達としておりました
ひょっとするとその友達はこう答えてくれました
だったら
趣味おねだりしみればいいんじゃないかなと
なんて気がつかなかったんですねそんなことを
趣味をネタにすることができれば自分が好きな音楽や力を
鉄道についての話がすることができますそしてその話を盛り上げて初の海を楽しむこと
ができる
そう思った私は最後の望みをかけて
趣味について人に聞いていくことにしました
その結果どうであったか
あなたの趣味は何ですか
食べる
寝る
人間観察
バッジ九スでした
今日はそういった話のネタに関するお話をしていこうと思っています
この話のネタという問題実はボクだけの問題ではありません
私たち日本人が全員抱えている問題でもありそして6年後に向けて私たちが
直していかなければならない問題の一つなんです
趣味について話をしているとこういった人にも出会いました
資格を取ることが趣味だという人です
近くを取るために勉強をしそしてその勉強を楽しみ
そして最終的に資格という形で認められる
それで満足感を得よう
そういう人たちです
日本には様々な資格が存在しています
そして日本人は視覚が大好きということで知られています
士郎示すある数字を
お伝えします
258万
昨年度1年間で世界共通の英語のテストである
遠いこれを日本で受けた人の数です
258万
膨大な数字です
そんな日本
その一方でこんなことも言われています
日本では英語が通じない
日本人は英語が話せない
どうしてなんでしょう
こんなにも勉強しているのに
こんなにたくさんの人が試験を受けているのになぜ私たちは話せないのか
なぜ私たちは話せないと思われないといけないんでしょうか
理由は3つあります
一つ目
私たちは
toeic の点数という一つの資格
それとうまく付き合いてないんです
私たちの敵は偏差値なんです
私たちはなぜ英語を勉強しますか
なぜ試験を受けますか
toeic の点数がなければ昇進や昇給就活が難しくなります
ましてや大学の授業でターンが出なくなります
そんな状況の中でどうやって英語を楽しめと言うんでしょうか
さらに悪いことに2020年オリンピックに向けて英語教育が変わろうとしています
しかしその方向も
今まで以上にテストが重視されてしまうようなそういった方向に変わっていってしまう
かもしれないんです
有名なテッドスピーカー教育学者の鍵ロビンソンという人がかつてこういうことを言っ
ておりました
現代の教育が重きを置いているのは
学ぶことや教えることではありません
現在の教育が重きを置いているものそれはそう
testing 試験なんです
私たちが英語を話せない理由二つ目
さあ一体何なんでしょうか
文法
単語発音
違うんです
なぜ離せないのか
話せないんじゃないんです
聞こえてないんです
私たちを含む英語を勉強している人はどうにも自信が持てません
私たちが英語を話す気
自身がガチめますするとどうしたことか私たちはだんだんと声が
声がちっちゃいと
当然相手には聞こえる
お相手は
こう尋ねこう聞き返すでしょう
ぱーどぅ
それ
アイペックよぱーどぅ
それにびっくりさ私たちはその大きな声にびっくりするとともに
同時にさまざまなショックを受け始めます私の文法が間違っていたの私の単語は違う私
の発音が違う
そして私の英語が間違っていたから伝わらなかったんだと
そしてその人は黙々と文法書をはじめ
単語帳ひたすら勉強し始めるでしょう
落ち着きましょう
声が少しで大きくしましょうそうすれば
スタールものは伝わります
この問題に対して一つ特効薬があるのをご存知でしょうか
お酒です
英語本場イギリスでこういったことが言われています
英語学習とお酒に関しての有名な言い回しです
ビールを3杯飲んだあなたはたちまち英語が堪能になるでしょう
その一方であなたからは文法という概念が失われます
ビールを6杯飲んだあなたあなたは突然英語の ng ワードを知ることになる
でしょう
そして現地の人と楽しく会話をすることができます
その一方であなたは羞恥心を失います
ビールを7杯以上飲んだあなたはおめでとうございます英語日本語に加えて第3の言語
を話し始めます
周りの人が言葉を失います
落ち着きましょう
声を大きくして
美人を持って喋れば大会のことは伝わります
3つめの問題これがあることを私たちは忘れてはいけません
3つのんだいこれはビールを述べ解決するものでもなく
なかなか一筋縄ではいかないんです
3つに問題数は何か
話す内容がないんです
これは私がイギリスに留学した時の話です
い下船倒錯したまさにその夜大学のバーに行きました
大学の場では既に到着している留学生が楽しそうに会話をしていました
その中に混じりたい
その他たちは勇み足で進んでいきました
私の話が苦手でしたしかしそこでお酒があります
万全の態勢で臨みました
最初は正しく海王することができました
どこから来たのうか
学校退学では何を勉強しているんですかどれぐらい対するんですか
といった内容で楽しく会をすることができました
しかし
ある出来事を境に
なんか会話の外にポンッと放り出されてしまうようなそんな感じがしました
日本について聞かれた時です
日本の周りでこういうことが起こっているらしいんだけどそれは何でなの
ウチの国ではこういうことはこういう風に言われてるんだけどじゃあ日本人はどう思っ
てるの
日本の9校ってさ一体何の意味があってこういうことやってんの
そういったないを立て続けに聞かれた時私は思わず
日本人に聞いて
っていう風に答えるしかありませんでした
話の内容についての知識がありませんでした
日本についての知識がありませんでした
自分の身の周りで何が起こっているのか
2つもりになっていたんです
英語を話せるようになりたいと思って文法や単語を必死に勉強していた私にとって
最初で最大のカルチャーショックでした
ところでみなさん
こんな単語を聞いたことがありますか
ミクシ
人をおちょくってるわけではありませんよ
某有名な sns とかそういったものではありません
ピン山の子で why
なぜといった意味を表す単語です
フィンランドの小学校の先生は
児童に対してこの日9 c という言葉を浴びせ続けます
あまりに浴びせ続けるのでその光景は陸士攻撃とまで呼ばれています
情報にあふれる現代に生きる私たち
私たちが今一番恐れなくてはならないことそれは
情報を鵜呑みにしてしまうことです
フィンランドを含むほかのさまざまな国では先生が子どもに対して歴史を開い
なぜということを徹底的に浴びせ続けます
そして子どもたちに分析をさせ
根拠をもって意見を持たせそして議論をさせます
その議論にや耳は聞こえません
批判的思考
クリティカルシンキングと呼ばれる考え方です
それを聞くとある人はこういます
日本はそれには向いてないんだ
日本語の言語の構造が違う
日本人はもともとそういうことに慣れてないから私たちは無理なんだと
英語がそういう構造だから外国はそういう構造だからの人たちができるんだ
そういう人があります
違うんです
私たちにもできるんです
mixi というこのことは
頭においていくだけで私たちにもできるんです
日本のある大学で英語学習とこの批判的思考
この2つに関する研究がなされました
英語の授業の中で議論やディベートを中心として英語の授業を行い
そしてその後に日本語でレポートを書く
そういった内容のものです
その結果
議論やディベートを経験した学生立つ
その人たちが書いたレポートは
他とは
比べ物にならないほど優れたものだったんです
きちんと論点が示されている根拠をもって意見が述べられている
ぎゃっ感的に2つのものを比較できている
これが示すものは何なのか
私たちにもできるんです
批判的思考を用いて分析をして
客観的に比べて意見を持つこと
控えめでおとなしく明確な意見を持たないと言われている日本人の私たちでもできるん
です
他の国でも
例えばインドネシアなんかでも英語学習
批判的思考この2つの
明らかな相関が見られていますそしてそういったタスクを中心とした授業によって学生
たちの思考を促すことができる
そう報告されているんです
昨年の8月にオーストラリアで教育実習を行いました
その時に
ある理科の先生が児童に向かってこういうことを言っていました
分析をしなさい
一人の政治家や一つの新聞が入っていることだけを鵜呑みにするのではなく自分たちで
科学的な根拠に基づいて分析をして意見を保ちなさい
それが私があなたたちに理科を教えている理由です
2020年
東京にオリンピックがやっていきます
それと同時に
英語の教育も変わります
オリンピックともなると世界中の目が
日本の中にそそがれるでしょう
そんなとき私たちが必要なものは何なのか
グローバルという外向きの視点ですか
テストのための英語ですか
違います
私たちは私たちが必要なものそれは
グローバルよりとローカルなんです
は雑誌は私たちはまず
自分の身の回りで何を怒っているのかをしっかりと把握すること
それが世界中の人が私たちに求めていることなんです
今日からこれは実践できると思います
分析をしましょう
意見を持ちましょう
そしてグローバルと呼ばれる現代を生き抜いていきましょう
グローバルに生きるグローバル時代に生きる皆さん
常にこの言葉を頭の中においてください
力士
ありがとうございました